lieber michael wie lange bereitest du
dich vor wie er arbeitest du denn die
rollen guckst du dir bänder an wie viel
zeit hat überhaupt beim drehen dafür wie
schafft es diese ganzen dialekte in
diesem einen körper zu verbinden diese
ganzen sprachen persönlichkeiten bist du
schizophren vielleicht keine ahnung oder
multiple persönlichkeit das gibt's ja
wie machst du das ich find's großartig
danke es ist eine mischung aus
schizophrenie und multiplen
persönlichkeiten es ist lässt sich
schwer in zeit fassen aber wir gucken
schon viele viele stunden dvds an und
studieren unsere opfer schreiben uns
fiel auf oder ich schreibe mir fiel auf
dann geht man mit der figur schwanger
das sind tage das sind manchmal auch
eine woche oder länger dauert es bis man
sich die figur drauf geschaffen hat die
dialekte keine ahnung die sind neben den
genen glaube ich in die wiege gelegt
worden und ja vielen dank für das
kompliment